all right many
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I was born in Mexico I
lived there until I was nine and a half
and then I came here to the U.S to L.A
been here since 1999.
how was your childhood
hmm
it was
it was good I feel like I spent most of
my childhood
um
it was good looking back now uh
you know the Mexico was probably I felt
like it was some of the best years
of my life I didn't have to worry about
who I was or
or none of that stuff really matters
that matters when you get older so
um
when I lived there it was just having
fun riding bikes and you know hanging in
the back of cars going hiding under the
cars playing tag
yeah being a kid so all that was good
um
for the most part I mean if you go into
detail you know
that was when I you know you need your
parents and I needed my mom and she was
focused on my dad cheating and uh
um I yeah most of like my first sexual
experiences happened when I was a kid uh
which was what led on to when I got
older which was what would be when I got
older what I um
came to like I guess I don't know you
know
um
I say that because a lot of people
growing up they're like yeah I never did
stuff like that when I was a kid but you
know early on I got introduced to
just um
sexual stuff I guess with with other
friends
um and all that stuff happened in Mexico
but for the most part I guess I like to
think about the good stuff I try to just
focus on the good was there anything
particularly traumatic about your
childhood
any abuse or
no I mean I used to think I was abused
by my cousin but now that I look back on
it I don't think it was abused I think
it was most it was just what introduced
me to what I would grow up to be into I
have I have a I had an older cousin two
years older than me girl cousin and Guy
cousin
and uh my guy cousin
I used to go to their house all the time
and one time he was like hey let's go in
the car let's go play so we went into
the truck and it was him and his brother
his brother's my same age he's two years
older he was like okay lay down right
there so I lay down right there he went
back to me
and he started like humping me and
fought like fondling me and I was
cracking up I thought it was funny like
what kind of game this is like a stupid
game and um
and then I was okay cool like now is
your brother's turn he's like no no I
like you
so uh I thought that was kind of hard
like that's weird and then we did that
like you know like three other times
um
and then after that I started I felt
like I started playing that game I was
like I kind of like that game and so
whenever I made a new friend you know we
would like hang out normal tag and then
I would like slowly start to play that
way like start little by little start
like uh
uh
just like a start touching them or
something and then we will get into that
and then that it will be like uh the
game and we were just [__] around
sexually
um at what age this was probably five
five of us want to start at five six
seven eight and then very young yeah
and then nine is when I came over here
so for that whole time when I came here
nothing happened it was like I forgot
about that the game
um
uh even as I got older you know I went
into high school then you know my
friends people started making out with
girls and uh having wanting my friends
started wanting to have a girlfriend and
and I was kind of like
I mean I did too because they did too
but
I never really found that kind of stuff
interesting so I pretended like I did I
feel like I should have or so I tried
but it wasn't the same I learned I know
now that it wasn't the same I wasn't
experiencing the same thing they were
experiencing and that went all through
High School
um
I try to get laid just because I felt
like I had to get laid but we went out
to clubs and they would be dancing the
goal for them was let's go out let's
meet a girl let's hook up so we can do
that thing and my whole thing was let's
go out and just hang out I just want to
hang out with my friends
um
until I was 21 which is when I uh
officially figured out like okay I'm gay
I didn't I I couldn't come to terms with
that too like for the last year then I
came out when I was like 21 so I think
on our 19 around 18 that's when I
started using drugs at 18 it was when um
that kind of stuff started popping up
because at 18 years old that's around
the end of senior year and that's when
uh
you know everybody's graduating so by
graduation if you watch movies uh I mean
it was like you know we're gonna get out
of high school we need to
well have a girlfriend so we can get
laid so we can go to college and be
experienced or something or or we're in
college where like that's when we
experience so it was around that age for
me where
that stuff was like right in front of my
face and uh depression kicked in and
anxiety kicked in and I started really
feeling weird because I was like why am
I not like the rest of my friends
so I didn't I I had tried to blend in
especially because I came from Mexico so
there was that whole part where I didn't
speak English and I was the weird kid
and that whole thing so I feel like a
lot of my life I was trying to I just
want to blend in because I did get
bullied for um not knowing the language
and just like not wearing a name brand
clothes
um
so while everybody was kind of like into
school trying to graduate trying to do
that stuff I was dealing with my
sexuality and just trying to like blend
in look like normal when inside I was
just [__] feeling like um
I don't know what's going on kind of
thing uh I Didn't Know Myself and I knew
that you know when I started
masturbating I would think about
guys and I was like one at one point I
was like you know what this is going to
be my secret I'm gonna
um
being to guys or think about this
and nobody's gonna know this I'll just
act like I'm into girls and it sounded
like it felt like a good idea to me when
I was probably like in seventh grade
which when that first started so I was
like this is just be my thing I'll just
do this secretly and pretend to be into
girls and um
yeah so that carried that that that took
me till senior year but that's when it
collapsed and it was like okay dude like
you don't have a girlfriend and then and
what made it worse was I was hanging out
with the the people I hung out with in
high school were kind of like cool kids
popular kids one of my friends was like
the guy who was hooking up with all the
girls so he was kind of like known and
he was a football player and another one
of my friends the same thing they were
all kind of into that kind of stuff
so I guess I was lucky I made cool
friends
but at the same time the pressure was so
much bigger and my flaws seemed that
much bigger like
yeah you're sticking out like a short
thumb because girls will start asking oh
yeah you know I know so-and-so hooked up
with her and he hooked up with her and
her and her but what about Manny like uh
I don't know of any girls that he's
hooked up with and he's just like you
guys you know you guys are all a group
of friends who kind of are in the same
thing and my friend was one time told me
he's like hey I looked out for you
uh so-and-so asked me what girls have
you [__] and I told them I told her oh
yeah Manny doesn't hook up with girls in
the school he he's better than that he
hooks up with girls that go to other
schools and and I was like oh yeah but
inside I was like damn that's
not good like your my friends are having
a life for me but they didn't know I was
gay but they're starting to lie for me
uh so yeah all that not knowing who I
was was probably
the most depressing and and and it gave
me anxiety and and I was just like
I really I didn't I didn't have a
personality so I really I wanted to be
black to be honest that was my thing
I've always loved black people and I've
always hung around black people uh so
that's why I surrounded myself with
until graduation
after graduated and everything
um
then I started doing started you know
experimenting with drugs
and then I went through this stage where
I just started hanging around gang
members I started working at a barber
shop actually and when I started working
in that barber shop you get all walks of
life in there
and I feel really awkward because people
will sit in the chair and they look at
you while you're cutting hair and I
remember telling my mom I feel weird
because people are just staring at me
and I'm so self-conscious of what
they're seeing like do I look gay do I
stand gay do I look feminine or
something yeah my mom's like Oh it's
normal people are their customers they
stare at you you're gonna get stared at
and that's all it took I was like okay
well that's cool that's
like I was able to let it go a little
bit
and when I you know being at the
barbershop you get a walk to life that's
what I started I think some of the
customers were like uh you know doing
drugs it was all gang members that would
come in and I felt like that's what a
man is I need to be like that because
those are real men you know nobody [__]
with them Nobody messes with those
people
so I started just getting involved with
those people started smoking weed uh
started drinking
and um
and and when I think when I started
doing drugs that's when
that was you know I always had that
secret right I'm gay so when I started
doing drugs I felt like it didn't matter
I I would get high
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
be this person this is who I am I'm the
guy who gets [__] up and go smokes
weed and and and
and that's it I'll be that person and um
so I became like a heavy you know I
smoked every day when I woke up after I
ate after I watched the movie before the
movies
before going to bed I was just high all
the time so people just knew me as that
person who smokes weed all the [__]
time and and I was hanging around these
gang members and that opened my mind to
a whole different thing
because when I was in high school you
know you had people who went in the
restroom and smoked weed and those were
kind of like lowlifes especially with
the friends I was with it was like yeah
you know there's that kid that guy he's
he's you know that group of people are
always getting high in the restroom you
don't want to be around those people and
so high school was kind of like that
perspective but then when I graduated
that helped me detach for my friends
because those guys were not that type of
person so when I went into the barber
shop and started getting clients who
were you know had tattoos in their face
smoked weed were you know uh selling
guns to each other and that kind of
thing I was like
these guys don't mess with these guys so
I'm gonna be one of those guys and they
won't be able to make fun of me anymore
or anything like that so it kind of made
me feel a little bit stronger
um
and
you know I'm talking about like we're
smoking under the bridge with I'm
hanging out homeless people uh and I
felt like I belonged there because
coming from Mexico in Mexico like I said
I went under the cars I hung in the back
of the car you know me and my friends
would wait for a car to stop at the stop
sign we'll hang from the back of it and
then take off and you know three miles
down the road to get off and then catch
another car to come back and I was a
dirty kid I didn't have you know my
brother would find me down the street
with no shoes no shirt on he and my mom
my mom was already here in the U.S
that's another part I left out I also
have OCD
um maybe that's part of it too how I go
off and let these tangents
have you uh gotten into trouble with the
law
no I've got no thankfully no I've gone
pulled over a bunch of times and uh when
I was younger
um I had a shaved head and the tattoos
and you know I was getting caught
smoking weed in like buy a trash can in
the back of a business so people I will
get pulled over because I looked like
the guy but then when we'll check
they'll check my record they were like I
can't believe you don't
they would just be like what the [__] so
you never you don't you don't have
anything you don't have an ID I don't
have an idea I'm an immigrant so I don't
I didn't have an idea at the time
and they just they couldn't believe I
like this guy looks like he needs to be
in jail I don't understand why there's
no record or anything and it was because
you know I that was what I did to
survive kind of I feel like it was like
tell me about the tattoo on your
forehead
uh so the tattoo on my Ford is pretty
much a middle finger to to all the
people who I grew up with who told me
being gay was wrong so this is like a
big [__] you to that like and and those
people you know they can uh they're very
religious I grew up with a very in a
very religious household so
uh being gay was wrong and
um like considered you know the whole
and that was religious two at a time so
yeah this whole thing will be like the
devil being gay is the devil so then I
kind of just understood like
is okay and the tattoo is kind of like
you know a big [__] you to that like no
it's fine I'll be that guy
um I'm the devil because people get
scared like he's gay and he has a tattoo
in his forehead and his upside down
cross I wonder what you know so it's
kind of like embracing that and it's
kind of punk rocking away too how do you
know 33.
he's going to limit your ability to get
jobs at certain places though I guess so
people say that but I'm a barber so I
kind of helps me people come into the
shop and they're like I feel like I look
more interesting so uh I've been doing
I've been cutting hair since 2007 which
is when I graduated high school
so right away I started cutting hair
and do you have kids like that no no I'm
like I said I've been with girls but it
doesn't do nothing for me it doesn't
work for me nothing happens the thing
that happens with you know straight
people
when there was a girl happens to me with
a guy
my same sex yeah yeah is it hard in your
community
to be gay
where I grew up at not so much anymore
but for a while yeah if I thought when I
because I I've when I came from
Mexico I moved to Paramount and I've
been there
I still work there I went to church
there I graduated high school there so
you know I see clients sometimes come in
and they're like
you know they come in I'm like wow I
remember that guy when he was like 13
and now he's like he has kids and he
doesn't know me but I've seen him
because I've been here and I remember I
have good memory I feel like uh so
yeah I thought when I came out they were
going to tie me to a tree and burn me
and watch me burn uh like my little by
little to you know to my co-workers to
my mom then to my co-workers so people
there everybody knows each other I feel
like it's a small City and if and when I
was in church I was very involved in
church right before coming out so I
would I would uh sing there and read
their the uh
so it was like I'm talking about it was
a mass pact of people people were didn't
even fit inside the church and it's a
big church and they will stick out there
were people standing outside so I would
have to like walk through the middle of
the you know the pathway with the priest
and there's just tons of people tons of
people you walk in the middle then you
go to the top you sit on a chair the
priest is in the middle
when I get up and start reading the
first reading then once I'm done the
priest gets up and reads the gospel uh
so yeah people saw me and so at first it
was like oh you're that guy that that
that
I see at church that sings
so people seen me I might not remember
all of them but they've seen my face you
know and now they see this guy with the
freaking upside down cross so they're
like what the [__] happened where you
love God now you hate God or something
so it's it's interesting but I don't if
I really am honest like I have my own
relationship with a higher power
um
I just don't with the
what is the song that says I never hated
a one true God but the god of the people
I hated
yeah do you but you you must be
getting a lot of judgment over that that
tattoo on your forehead I guess well I
guess I could tell when people see me
usually as ladies like moms they come
they I could tell they look on their
face and I thought it was going to take
get religious people away from me but it
kind of brought them like the other day
I was at work right and this girl comes
in they're like hey you want to donate
to the church and I'll and uh I was like
no that's okay not today and she's like
brother you have a I see that you have a
cross on your forehead I was like yeah
yeah but it looks like it's upside down
I was like yeah it is and then while I'm
shaving some guy's face and she puts her
hand on my shoulder and she just starts
praying for me and I could have been
like hey I'm not okay with that but I
didn't I just let her do that I'm
shaving the dude's face and she's like
praying over me and then another time I
was going to lunch and these two guys
are walking past me and they're like
staring at me
um whatever I don't know I forget that I
have things written on my face and then
after she they're like hey bro can I
talk to you like yeah we're like how
come you have the upside down cross on
your forehead and I was like I just like
it I think it's uh I I think it's kind
of punk rock
um they're like yeah but do you know
what that means I was like yeah in
Christianity means you know Saint Peter
was going to get crucified but he didn't
want to be crucified he didn't think he
was worthy of being crucified like Jesus
did so he wanted to be crucified upside
down
um so that or it could mean that I like
Satan I'm okay with both whatever you
think
how bad is your OCD it's good now it's
kind of like dormant right now I feel
like but when I'm going through a crisis
it gets bad I've seen it get to the
point where it's crippling and you know
I'm washing my hands 30 times my hands
assuming my hands are pretty dry right
now so there's still things that I do
like I get on my knees and pray every
night a certain time I have to do that
prayer if not it kind of sticks in the
back of my head if something bad's gonna
happen so I've noticed is that where I
clinched my teeth so those are the
little things that I that are still
there
that I don't notice but when I'm going
through a crisis it's irrational stuff
like making sure the door is locked and
I watched myself lock it but I stand
there and I'm like lock unlock unlock
for like I don't know 15 times so I've
heard in here it was it was very freeing
to hear somebody say about the
pedophilia and suicide so when it gets
really bad I start thinking that I want
to kill myself or that I'm a pedophile I
didn't know that was a regular thing I
just thought I was [__] crazy and
weird you learned that from another
video on my channel yeah and I was like
oh my God I'm not the only one but I
went to therapy and was like I think I'm
a pedophile I think I you know because I
see kids and now and then I wonder if
like did I look at that person in a
certain way and then I have to stare and
then I'm afraid that I'm not that I'm
staring they're going to think like why
are you staring and like oh my God I am
so
they get super irrational I have to tell
people and what I found for me having
OCD I need validation it helps me if
some people like no you're not you're
not suicidal I can't walk
you know I can walk near Edge because
then if the thought comes up
I'm not gonna do it I've learned that of
people with OCD are some of the
friendliest safest people but you you
your pedophilic thoughts are not real
yeah it's just fear yeah but who tells
you that you know nobody tells you like
oh they're just thoughts like regular
people don't
I don't feel like regular people
have to process things like that
so when I had to do that I was like it
was a fight between like no no this is
not normal you don't be you're thinking
too much into it you're just are or
you're not and I had to I got to the
point where I was like you know what
maybe I am and I have to be okay with
going with uh going to jail maybe I
don't have to go to jail so I have to
bring it up to my therapist like hey you
know so I think I am do I get locked up
and she's like you can't lock you up for
your thoughts you don't go to jail for
thoughts and I was like okay that and
sometimes all I need is something like
that to tell somebody to tell me that
and I'm okay
and I'm talking about from being 100
going from 100 to zero like my my OCD is
like 100 and then it's like dormant uh
but but I've learned that just from some
reassurance yeah reassurance but I'm
learning to just I'm I'm trying to
reassure myself I shouldn't be codepa
I'm also codependent
and I think that overlaps with my OCD so
I'm going to therapy for codependence
um you see a therapist huh yeah
psychologist like I have to get
medication for my OCD anxiety and my
major depression because it all just
having OCD I'm aware of what I'm doing
is irrational
and that makes me depressed and then
being depressed I'm like I'm depressed
[__] like why am I like this or then
that even makes me more depressed
because like it's not like like it's not
like schizophrenia I don't know much
about schizophrenia but like people who
are schizophrenic I think they're just
like they're okay they're happy like
yeah you know I see Batman and that's
okay and or I hear your mind I know that
to me it's like no no no no I know that
what I'm doing it's not making sense but
I can't help myself from from thinking
it and making sure I'm not doing these
things
so that makes me depressed too so I'm
taking medication the medication isn't
perfect they're just kind of like gives
me a little boost but then I have to you
know meditation has helped me a lot
because meditation is not running with
your thoughts you know things come into
your head and you just watch them pass
and you relax and you're in the moment
what's really happening what's really
happening is I'm here sitting down and
I'm constantly breathing that is
happening breathing not
everything else starts just come and go
so that's been crucial journaling
because I just like throw up all my
thoughts into the paper
uh so little things like that have made
big help environments what's the hardest
thing you struggle with OCD
the expression yeah you know I think the
when I think back to my life the hardest
moments in my life were
that when the OCD spiked up
and the anxiety and panic attacks
because that all comes to panic attacks
are the worst but they've happened so
much to me that I think I've learned how
to
manage them like I used to have a panic
attack and have
A bad month like I'll lose so much
weight people were like what the hell is
wrong with you and I then I will start
getting the suicidal thinking I'm like I
think I'm gonna die I think I'm gonna
kill my like what if I get I'll be like
what if I get so depressed that I want
to kill myself is this what people go
through do they get like this and I'll
like take a break from everything social
media don't go out any other
yeah um people say like I've heard
people say that when you're stressed out
that's when like you get gray hairs so
as I've grown older and I look at
pictures from me from high school or
stuff like that I see like this like
wrinkles started coming in and uh it's
probably normal of Aging but I'm like
wow probably because of those because I
could count in one hand the times that
I've gone through that depression and
crisis like I call it spiral down
and coming out of that has just been
like
it's like um
surviving almost feels like surviving to
be honest because
it's not life going through that having
those moments of panic not learning to
deal with it
or hell and I'm just grateful that I've
had like the I don't know what the hell
it is where I'm like I can't die I can't
die I have to find help find a therapist
psychiatrist it takes a village because
they'll take you know the doctor and the
psychiatrist and the medication and the
and the the meetings I go to AAA and all
that stuff and then you know have a
sponsor and talk to people and it takes
a lot of people to get me
to go around in the world like a normal
person
to be able to hold a regular
conversation I have to do these things
drugs or alcohol are not really a big
problem for you
well not anymore I I've been so over
eight years
and I feel like I need to be sober in
order to kind of be mentally balanced
because if I'm not then I start getting
um
like psycho I've had psychosis I had
this tattoo in my stomach of this dog
that I once saw when I was
younger I was like smoking weed and
drinking and ecstasy and cocaine and I
came home one time and I saw this dog
two dogs
and I thought like I thought I saw the
devil
and now when I look back at it I'm like
you know what
what's the what's the most rational
thought I was probably super high like
really [__] up in my head
and it probably was just two dogs that
got lost and came into their apartment
and because I was so [__] up I thought
it was like this evil thing especially
because
the church thing you know that cult
thing's always been you get like PTSD
from the church stuff especially even
like God's Gonna punish you and all you
want to do is be what I did all I wanted
to do was be a good kid obedient to my
mom and you know that whole thing but
then [__] happens you know your cousin
touches you and you like it and now you
do it so then you were just like he is
um so now God was I'm kicked out of
paradise or something and
with OCD I feel like God's this like
evil cop person that's like always
looking at me and watching me and
everything I do is wrong and then so I
try to be perfect with ocds like trying
to be perfect so it's like
[__] heavy so the upside down cross
almost makes me feel like [__] that that
whole idea of it I don't want it I want
a God who loves me cares for me who
isn't punishing me or watching over me
making sure like I do everything perfect
I don't want that that's what they've
taught me and so that doesn't work for
me
Manny what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
that's hard because
with me and my OCD I feel like every
time something helps me to get out of
the obsession
that's my [__] life-saving thing so
whether it be don't you know
you know don't uh run with your thoughts
that's going to change everything I'm
cured now you know but
I think uh at the moment is and
everybody has a different thing right
people who people who grew up trusting
themselves their whole life
are now trying to believe in something
else and believe in other people but for
me I've been codependent I trust
everybody else's opinion over my own so
if I think if I think the sky is blue
and you tell me no it's pink I'm like
maybe it is pink I'm wrong so for now
I'm in a place where like I need to
trust myself I can now start to trust me
and and and listen to what I feel inside
and go with that
and and of course there's probably going
to be a balance because I'll probably do
too much of that in the next chapter of
my life and then I'll experienced some
bad stuff with that and then I have to
bring it back
but I don't have to kill myself over it
well that maybe that's to this I have a
tattoo myself just Live and Let Live
because I grew up with a lot of
controlling people so just live don't
die
if you just stick around [__] gets
better you if you feel like I feel like
you know I feel like I had to kill
myself for the [__] that happened two
years ago and I stuck around and I'm
here doing this thing and this is
awesome I thought I experienced it all
two months ago I thought I was it
there's no more than that and then I
stuck around and like great things
happen and then I realized I was wrong I
I was wrong if I just stick around and
stay alive there's so much more I
haven't lived you know and that's been
proven to me over and over again and
maybe that's the higher power thing you
know but yeah just just live don't die
all right Manny thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you good luck
with the OCD and everything else thank
you